I still feel responsible for the
accident oh I cannot wait the ladies of
Monterey are trying to keep their
secrets safe with big little lies
returned Sunday and to celebrate that
we're flashing back to et's time with
the cast now and then are you prepared
for what could happen to your career
after being in a huge blockbuster hit no
I don't know how you would prepare for
it he first met Nicole Kidman in 1994
her breakout film Days of Thunder the 22
year old up-and-comer just confirmed she
was in a relationship with her very
famous co-star I am involved with the
Tom Cruise yes he's a very high-profile
person you know one of the most famous
actors in the world Reese Witherspoon
played a lovesick teenager in her 1991
film debut the man in the moon would be
the first boy I ever kissed me and
that's pretty much the way she was in
real life during our first et interview
that first kiss was in a roller skating
rink it was 12 years old and I had a
boyfriend and it was Graham and pretty
good while Reese is now one of the
hottest producers in Hollywood back then
she just wanted the grown-ups to call
the shots people want to make you have
like all these big decisions and stuff
then finally I just I I just kind of sit
down and say I don't know I'm 15 years
old you figure out for me I don't know
Shailene Woodley was 16 years old when
et met her on the set of The Secret Life
of the American teenager is the only
good thing that's happened to me this
year I'm a normal girl who happens to
have acting as my hobby and I happen to
love it but you know I'm not in it for
anything other than the hobby Laura Dern
was raised by two Hollywood legends
Bruce Dern and Diane Ladd et met her in
1986 when she began getting her own
Oscar buzz for the film smooth talk I've
been around and you know my life like
the Oscars is such an honor I've heard
it but I try not to let it
zoe kravitz was just nine years old in
1998 when she was mom Lisa Bonet plus
one at the enemy of the state
after-party what do you think if I see
mom up there on a big screen I like this
[Applause]
[Music]